et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Nicolas meilleur Rossignol bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous mère de Rouen
1er secrétaire délégué du Parti
socialiste on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane
pour commencer par ce qui s'est passé
hier à l'Assemblée nationale et cette
motion de censure qui n'est donc pas
passé il a manqué 50 voix pour faire
tomber le gouvernement est-ce que vous
avez définitivement perdu la bataille
politique sur la réforme des retraites
non je ne crois pas je ne crois que la
bataille elle va continuer tout
simplement parce que nous sommes en
démocratie et il y aura des rendez-vous
devant les les urnes et les Français
devront choisir en fait Valérie rabot en
2027 notamment mais il y a d'autres
élections avant mais non effectivement
en 2027 Valérie Rabault qui était
l'oratrice notamment pour les
socialistes hier la dit je crois avec
beaucoup de force il y a deux sujets il
y a le contenu de la réforme des
retraites et puis il y a la question du
processus parlementaire et du respect du
débat démocratique au sein du Parlement
pas un petit sujet quand même et c'est
vrai que là le Parlement n'a pas été
respecté on a une contradiction par
rapport à des usages qui sont établis
depuis 1958 donc c'est en réalité une
situation grave et il faut l'aborder
avec gravité alors c'est pas c'est pas
la bataille politique qui a été perdue
au Parlement c'est la bataille la
bataille du Parlement sur le réforme des
retraites qui se terminent par contre
vous êtes en train de nous ouvrir que il
y a un nouveau front qui s'ouvre autour
d'une d'une réforme d'une réforme de la
Constitution et des institutions qui est
nécessaire je pense qu'il y a deux
fronts sur les retraites nous avons dit
que une fois élu nous abrogerons la
réforme il faut aussi dire ce que nous
ferons à la place vous connaissez ma
position par rapport aux 60 ans etc et
puis à la question effectivement
la position du PS c'est pas forcément
très clair non et je l'ai déjà donné
pour les 62 ans enfin est-ce que vous
êtes pour les 62 ans est-ce que vous
êtes pour un retour à 60 ans moi je l'ai
déjà dit à plusieurs reprises nous avons
écrit des choses très claires je pense
que il faut pas parce qu'on serait dans
l'opposition ou en conquête électorale
sentir aux gens est-ce qu'on fera demain
la retraite à 60 ans pour tous quarante
à nuités pour tous la réponse est non ça
n'est pas vrai ça n'est pas sincère par
contre est-ce qu'on doit se battre donc
ce qui est dans l'accord de la nuque
c'est pas sincère non je pense que ça
n'est pas sincère je les ai déjà dit je
pense que ça n'est pas sincère mais en
revanche je pense qu'il est très
important de se battre pour que les
métiers les plus pénibles les métiers
les plus utiles sur le plan social et
écologique je pense à l'hôpital à la
santé à l'éducation qui aujourd'hui sont
mal reconnus voire pas reconnu puisse
bénéficier d'une meilleure retraite et
de plus largement de meilleures
conditions de travail voilà là où la
gauche doit être doit être non pas dans
la posture mais dans des propositions
utiles là où c'est le plus utile pour
ceux de nos concitoyens qui sont les
plus modestes les plus fragiles et qui
exercent les métiers les plus utiles à
notre société pourquoi l'électorat de
gauche devrait vous croire vous avez
dénoncé en 2010 la réforme menée par
Eric verte en disant que c'était une
réforme injuste et que si la gauche
arrive au pouvoir vous reviendriez
dessus en 2012 vous êtes arrivé au
pouvoir non seulement vous n'êtes pas
revenu dessus mais en plus avec la
réforme Touraine vous avez allongé la
durée d'annuité pourquoi cette fois
l'électorat de gauche devrait vous
croire est-ce que du coup vous n'avez
pas un manque de crédibilité là c'est
pour ça que je vous dis que vous venez
de dire le mot le plus important c'est
la crédibilité moi je me refuse c'est la
maxime de Pierre Mendès France je
m'astreinte à dire la vérité autant
quand on est dans l'opposition que quand
on est au responsabilité et je pense que
ça ne serait pas sincère de faire croire
en particulier au plus modeste d'entre
nous au plus modeste de nos concitoyens
et qui qui ont un espoir en la gauche de
faire de leur faire croire des choses
que nous ne ferions pas vous venez de
rappeler l'histoire une fois arrivé aux
responsabilités donc j'essaye d'être
honnête et il y a des choses qu'on peut
faire parce que le monde du travail a
changé parce qu'il y a des métiers qui
sont très mal valorisés et c'est là que
la gauche doit porter son effort
franchement Laurent Berger dit pas autre
chose à la CFDT il dit la mesure de
couper sur l'âge légal de la retraite la
mesure la plus injuste il a raison et il
dit la mesure la plus juste c'est la
modulation la durée de cotisation vous
avez des gens qui ont des métiers très
peu pénibles je la fais courte qui
pourrait travailler plus longtemps vous
avez des gens qui ont des métiers très
pénibles et qui sont très mal valorisés
dans notre société injustement alors ça
oui on les a applaudis pendant la
pandémie mais quand on arrive au concret
au sauna et trébuchant si j'ose dire
alors là il est plus personne c'est là
que la gauche doit être et puis il y a
la question que vous posiez sur le
problème démocratique Valérie rabot l'a
dit hier avec beaucoup de force j'invite
tout le monde à écouter ce qu'elle a dit
elle dit le Parlement là doit être
respecté il ne l'est plus et elle a
raison parce que sans langue de bois
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pression du
gouvernement et du président de la
République sur la présidente et voilà
alors que les amendements contenaient
des dispositions qui avaient été
reconnus recevable à la fois par le
président de la commission des finances
Eric coquerelles mais aussi par le
Bureau de l'Assemblée nationale donc là
on a un précédent et comme elle l'a dit
c'est la porte ouverte à l'arbitraire ça
c'est très dangereux mais il faut
réformer les institutions il faut il
faut changer la Constitution il faut
faut changer de République ah bah
mauvaise République Mélenchon encore une
fois je pense que les slogans c'est
c'est bien ce qui compte c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait déjà en pratique parce que là
en l'occurrence c'est une pratique c'est
c'est un changement de pratique sous
pression du gouvernement plutôt pratique
de l'Assemblée nationale c'est d'abord
le premier sujet et puis le deuxième
sujet c'est de respecter les électeurs
moi je fais partie comme des millions de
Françaises et de français de gens qui
ont voté pour Emmanuel Macron au second
tour en 2022 mais qui n'ont pas voté
pour cette réforme des retraites et puis
vous avez vu les manifestations et puis
vous avez vu les sondages et puis vous
avez vu le front unanime des syndicats
donc voilà c'est là où on a un problème
démocratique qui faille des réformes et
qu'il faille travailler dessus très bien
on aura un débat présidentiel en 2027
là-dessus très bien mais d'abord il y a
l'exercice du pouvoir et on voit bien
qu'à force à force de jouer Jupiter
Jupiter Jupiter je suis désolé la France
c'est pas l'Olympe quoi un mot sur
l'immigration puisque ce qui s'est passé
à Annecy jeudi dernier a relancer le
débat politique sur la politique
migratoire la réforme du droit d'asile
Elisabet qui appelle les parlementaires
à travailler sur le projet de loi
immigration est-ce que le Parti
socialiste va travailler avec le
Gouvernement sur ce texte le Parti
socialiste il doit toujours être au
travail et il doit pas y avoir de sujets
tabou moi je suis maire de Rouen je peux
vous dire que les questions liées au
migrations aux migrants à l'accueil des
réfugiés à l'intégration à la mixité
sociale pour ainsi dire on se les
colline on y travaille tous les jours et
et heureusement avec les associations il
y a plein de gens qui travaillent sur
ces sujets tous les jours est-ce qu'on a
besoin tous les quatre matins excusez
mon langage un peu direct mais d'une
énième loi sur l'immigration dont
personne n'est dupe sur le fait que il
s'agit d'un énorme clin d'oeil vis-à-vis
de allez la droite pour pas dire la
droite extrême ça je suis pas certain
parce que franchement
j'en suis pas certain en tout cas on
voit bien la manipulation politique et
c'est pas la première de ces lois vous
souvenez de quand Monsieur Sarkozy était
président de la République on avait des
lois immigration bon est-ce que ça a
changé fondamentalement les choses non
donc je pense que c'est pas là par
contre où on attend la gauche où est-ce
qu'on attend à gauche là je pense que
c'est très important je pense que la
gauche elle doit d'abord porter des
valeurs moi les valeurs que je porte
sont des valeurs humanistes la
Méditerranée aujourd'hui c'est un
cimetière faire croire que les
migrations vont s'arrêter demain c'est
un mensonge parce que nous avons des
réfugiés climatiques parce que nous
avons des inégalités mondiales qui se
sont accrues et donc il faut prendre le
sujet à bras le corps le premier sujet
c'est pas un grand remplacement les
volumes le nombre de personnes
concernées et largement raisonnable par
rapport à la taille de notre pays en
revanche ce qui est vrai c'est que dans
les territoires on a des hétérogénéités
parce que vous avez certains quartiers
certaines communes qui accueillent
beaucoup beaucoup plus que d'autres et
donc vous avez des phénomènes de perte
de mixité sociale liés au logement lié à
l'attribution des logements c'est là
qu'on doit travailler pas une énième loi
pour faire de la posture mais
travaillons avec les territoires avec
les maires avec les Héli locaux sur le
logement sur la mixité sociale sur la
rénovation urbaine sur l'accueil sur les
associations qui bossent sur ces sujets
et je vous assure quand on fait ça
on a plein d'exemples de migrants qui
s'intègrent très bien on a plein
d'exemples non seulement de migrants qui
s'intègre très bien mais qui participent
activement j'allais dire non seulement
l'activité économique mais à la fierté
des valeurs que la France porte de façon
universelle
Stéphane on va parler politique il s'est
passé samedi oui Bernard Cazeneuve a
réuni plus de 2000 socialistes autour de
lui Samedi dernier vous n'y étiez pas
pourquoi alors pour une raison
extrêmement personnelle et familiale
c'est que j'étais coincé chez moi pour
garder mes enfants voilà c'est très
simple
je l'ai dit d'ailleurs dans une vidéo
que j'ai que j'ai faite à l'intention de
vous
soutenez son mouvement non je suis
socialiste donc je reste socialiste
j'allais presque vous dire il y avait
des socialistes bien sûr et en fait ce
que j'essaye de dire c'est que d'abord
vers marcazen c'est un ami c'est un
homme d'État un ami normand vous savez
qu'on est tous les deux et lui de
Normandie lui de la Manche et de
Cherbourg mois de Rouen en
Seine-Maritime on a fait des campagnes
ensemble c'est un ami militant c'est un
ami socialiste et c'est un homme d'État
et je pense qu'on en a besoin pour la
gauche on peut pas dire d'un côté la
gauche est faible tout le monde se
rejoint là-dessus la gauche doit se
rassembler on doit avoir une gauche
large moi je porte une gauche large plus
large plus équilibrée
et dès qu'il y a quelqu'un qui pense un
peu différemment l'exclure donc on doit
travailler avec Bernard Cazeneuve et
avec d'autres Bernard Cazeneuve
David hassouline le disait chez vous il
y a hier
il porte le centre gauche nous au Parti
socialiste et chez refondations le
mouvement que nous avons créé nous
voulons porter le centre de la gauche
parce qu'on a besoin de rééquilibrer
cette gauche aujourd'hui elle est trop
souvent malheureusement dans l'outrans
et en même temps on doit parler avec
tout le monde nous nous parlons avec LFI
avec les écologistes avec les
communistes avec les radicaux de gauche
qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui dans l'anus
avec Bernard Cazeneuve parce qu'on a
besoin de tout cela alors c'est un
problème qu'il est quitté le parti
socialiste pour vous il ne peut pas
incarner sur rassemblement n'ayant
quitté le PS mais je viens sur votre
plateau pour dire à tous ceux qui ont
quitté ces dernières années le Parti
socialiste pour des raisons que je peux
comprendre tout le monde peut avoir ses
doutes c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des
échecs etc depuis cinq six mois à peine
nous avons créé ce courant au sein du
Parti socialiste qui s'appelle
refondation vous avez vu les résultats
nous représentons aujourd'hui
la moitié pour le dire rapidement du
Parti socialiste je dis à tous ceux qui
ont été déçus qui pensaient qu'ils ne se
passaient plus rien à partitioniste mais
revenez revenez
nous travaillons ensemble revenez au
Parti socialiste ça se joue à quelques
voix si vous revenez on va peser plus
fort et nous pourrons remettre le Parti
social et surtout le socialisme parce
que c'est ça qui compte c'est à dire la
lutte contre toutes les injustices les
injustices sociales écologiques d'abord
au cœur de la gauche c'est de ça dont on
a besoin on a pas besoin de créer son
propre mouvement Bernard cazen il doit
rejoindre mais c'est très bien non c'est
très bien qu'il y ait des mouvements ce
que je veux dire c'est que et d'ailleurs
il le dit lui-même la convention n'est
pas exclusive on peut appartenir à
d'autres formations politiques mais je
sais que beaucoup de militants de
camarades je l'ai vu dans ma fédération
je l'ai vu par tout en France c'est pas
un secret le Parti socialiste c'est cinq
dernières années il a perdu énormément
de militants il avait perdu avant et on
en a perdu après bon c'est un constat
j'attaque personne en disant ça c'est la
réalité des chiffres bon on peut trouver
que c'est mieux ici moins mal à boire
j'en sais rien au global on peut pas
dire qu'on est gagné beaucoup bon ça
veut dire que aujourd'hui il se passe
quelque chose on était à Montpellier on
a eu des intellectuels des responsables
politiques de différentes formations
politiques qui viennent travailler parce
qu'on a envie
de remettre une force centrale qui ne
soit pas dans un retour vers le passé
parce que le monde a changé et qu'on a
besoin de changer notre logiciel
François Hollande Jean-Christophe
Cambadélis est-ce que c'était pas un peu
la résurgence du socialisme passé mais
moi j'aime pas faire du jeunisme
expliqué que parce que on serait vous
savez Brassens ça tout dit là-dessus je
crois que c'est le temps ne fait rien à
faire et c'est une pirouette mais mais
ça dit quand même beaucoup de choses je
pense qu'on a besoin de tout le monde et
que si on commence à dire sous prétexte
de rassembler qu'il faut exclure je
pense qu'il y a une contradiction dans
les termes c'est pas parce qu'on a tel
âge non il faut être lucide sur le fait
que le monde a changé et que donc on a
besoin d'un logiciel je pense beaucoup
plus écologique par exemple c'est vrai
que le Parti socialiste a longtemps été
assez productiviste bon là il y a des
changements à mettre en oeuvre le monde
a changé et puis il faut aussi qu'on
évite le social populisme pour le dire
rapidement c'est-à-dire éviter l'outrans
et puis éviter les tabous vous avez
parlé de l'immigration tout à l'heure il
faut en parler sérieusement
la sécurité c'est un enjeu extrêmement
important c'est qu'il social populaire
le social populiste c'est quand vous
commencez à dire des choses pour flatter
un électorat pour flatter ou faire
croire à des Françaises et des Français
pour gagner des voix alors que vous
savez très bien que vous ne le ferez pas
demain exemple quand vous dites 60 ans
40 à nuité pour tout le monde je pense
que c'est dangereux parce que vous avez
beaucoup de Françaises et de Français
qui vont y croire et demain si nous
sommes en responsabilité que nous le
faisons pas alors là c'est le pire et
c'est ça qui amène ensuite l'abstention
ou pire le vote vers l'extrême droite
donc c'est la ligne du PS qui suit la
Nupe c'est surtout une incarnation qui
est portée par pas tout le monde
d'ailleurs mais par une partie de la
France insoumise qui pour des raisons
qu'on peut très bien comprendre qui sont
liés aux élections de 2022 aujourd'hui
domine le rassemblement de la gauche à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est le résultat
des ions de 2022
personne chez personne je pense une
partie et malheureusement de mon point
de vue le Parti socialiste aujourd'hui
n'est pas assez clair sur ce qu'il a à
proposer nous nous avons fait des
propositions sur les retraites on peut
s'opposer mais pour bien s'opposer il
faut s'opposer et proposer si on ne
propose rien on n'est pas crédible moi
sur le marché à Rouen les gens ils me
disent bon on a bien compris la réforme
de Monsieur Macron elle est injuste elle
est inacceptable oui on va l'abroger OK
et alors après vous faites quoi et alors
vous allez vous poser quoi
l'assemblée ils n'ont rien proposé je
pense que Boris Vallot et beaucoup
d'autres Jérôme Guedj Arthur de la porte
Philippe Brun Valérie rabot et j'en
oublie ont eu le mérite de débusquer les
injustices vous vous souvenez par
exemple sur les 1200 euros sur les
carrières pénibles sur la question des
carrières des femmes et c'est très
important mais quand vous sortez de
l'Assemblée nationale pour la plupart
des Français la nups c'est elle est fi
c'est Monsieur Mélenchon je sais que
c'est injuste ça peut paraître
irrationnel c'est la réalité
pourquoi et je n'attaque personne en
disant ça parce que il me semble et mais
c'est une aussi une autocritique il me
semble que nous socialistes ne sommes
pas assez fort dans sa pas assez clair
expressif sur ce que nous nous avons à
dire et à proposer on a parlé de
l'immigration la sécurité l'Europe nous
sommes pour européens il faut le dire
les retraites la pénibilité
et la valorisation des métiers les plus
utiles sur le plan social et écologique
dans nos sociétés voilà les combats on
doit avancer est-ce que vous pouvez être
fort quand vous faites 1,78% à la
présidentielle on part on part de très
loin mais en 2017 aussi on avait fait un
très mauvais score et puis souvenez-vous
en 93 si on fait un peu d'archéologie
les socialistes et la gauche prennent
une claque au législatives bon et en 95
manque de peu de gagner et en 97 après
la dissolution il y a une majorité de
gauche les choses peuvent changer moi
surtout ce que je crois c'est qu'on n'a
jamais eu autant besoin de socialisme
toutes les forces de gauche vous avez
été de prévenir les écologistes par
France insoumise qui a fait 10 fois plus
que vous la politique ce sont d'abord
des convictions et des idées on doit pas
être guidé par je ne sais quel accord
électoral par je ne sais quelle constat
d'un résultat oui c'est vrai on a pris
des claques oui c'est vrai on a été
mauvais à certains moments et on a fait
des choses bien aussi et on va pas
s'excuser de ça mais moi j'essaie de
regarder vers l'avant j'appartiens à une
nouvelle génération qui va apporter une
nouvelle énergie c'est le cas de Valérie
rabot que j'ai cité tout à l'heure je
pourrais vous citer Michael de la fosse
Carole delgat voilà il y a des gens qui
ont envie et moi je le vois partout dans
les territoires et vous savez pourquoi
parce qu'on n'a jamais eu autant besoin
de socialisme parce qu'on n'a jamais eu
autant besoin de lutte contre les
injustices et c'est ça qui compte c'est
pour ça que je dis à toutes celles et
ceux qui ont pu être déçus mais revenez
parce que c'est à l'intérieur qu'on peut
peser si vous êtes à l'extérieur vous
pouvez pleurer sur le lait renversé mais
vous pouvez pas influer sur le cours des
choses pourquoi moi je me suis engagé
alors que je suis maire de Rouen
j'aurais pu très bien rester sur mon
avantin comme on dit bon mais je me suis
engagé parce que j'ai envie de faire
bouger les choses et pour bouger les
choses il faut bouger à l'intérieur donc
revenez et battons-nous ensemble vous
entendu parler de d'archéologie
élector électoral vous disiez tout à
l'heure vous avez dit à l'instant là que
le refondation votre mouvement faisait
la moitié du Parti socialiste vous
comptez pas un peu large quand même moi
je me fais je fais référence au vote qui
a été très contesté d'ailleurs de
janvier oui au second tour mais le
premier tour d'émotion vous votre
émotion elle faisait pas 50 % d'ailleurs
vous avez noté
elle était donc pas majoritaire comment
vous vous entendez aujourd'hui avec
Olivier Faure oui parce que j'essaye de
vous dire tout simplement c'est que on
l'a vu au congrès de Marseille quel que
soit les chiffres le parti séisme il a
été divisé et il est divisé en deux et
et il y a mais parce qu'il y a un débat
qui est sain en fait et franchement pas
purger mais Olivier fauve mais c'est pas
une question personnelle moi je n'ai
absolument rien de personnel vis-à-vis
ni d'Olivier ni vis-à-vis de personnes
et je trouve que je vous dites le
premier secrétaire doit pas être le
premier secteur c'est un peu personnel
quand même non non parce que je pense
sincèrement quand vous pouvez pas dire
il faut rassembler toute la gauche et
commencer par dire à vos propres
camarades partez on veut plus vous voir
regarder la violence des propos qui sont
tenus entre par exemple Bernard
Cazeneuve et Olivier Faure je pense que
c'est pas une très bonne idée surtout
quand on regarde l'histoire
d'olivier et d'autres voilà avant qu'on
met Marseille avant le congrès de
Marseille Olivier fort vous avez proposé
de prendre la tête de la liste Europe
des européennes
vous aviez refusé non mais vous avez
vous en êtes où aujourd'hui avec lui sur
ce sujet non travaillons
qui sont socialistes qui font un bon
travail avec les autres textes
orientation c'est un bon travail et on
avance ensemble en revanche je pense que
la direction du Parti socialiste doit
dire beaucoup plus clairement comme l'a
fait Fabien Roussel comme l'a fait
Mariton delé comme l'a fait Raphaël
Glucksman que pour notre part nous avons
des valeurs des convictions et qu'il y a
des choses qui ne sont pas négociables
là-dessus nous pouvons être critique sur
les politiques européennes mais nous
sommes pro-européens et faire une liste
avec des partenaires que nous respectons
qui ont d'autres mauvaise idée mais qui
refusent jusqu'aux drapeau européen dans
leur salle de meeting c'est juste pas
possible et c'est pas grave et c'est un
débat démocratique on va avoir une liste
commune avec la France Olivier fort
disait la même chose le 4 janvier
dernier vérifié ses publics et c'est sur
Internet est-ce qu'on peut juste être
cohérent est-ce qu'on peut acheter cette
cohérent avec notre histoire avec
Jacques Delors avec François Mitterrand
et c'est ce que les Françaises et les
Français attendent et ensuite ils votent
en conscience moi j'ai proposé un
Erasmus pour tous on a besoin d'une
nouvelle utopie pour l'Europe qu'une
nouvelle génération européenne que
chaque nouvelle génération européenne
puisse faire au moins 6 mois nourri
loger blanchi quel que soit votre niveau
d'études dans un autre pays l'Union
européenne voilà un voir c'est là où on
attend la gauche les accords d'appareils
franchement est-ce que c'est ça
qu'attendre les Françaises et les
Français
ça sert à quoi sinon la politique si
vous ne dites pas ce que vous êtes
est-ce que vous souhaitez vous dispaez
une espèce publique comme ça a été le
cas il y a 5 ans moi je souhaite d'abord
qu'on dit ce que l'on est nous quel
utopie quel espoir quelle proposition
exemple
Erasmus pour tous c'est clair il y a du
souffle il y a de l'espoir ensuite on
regarde qui est proche de nous sur le
fond on commence par regarder et toi tu
me donnes quelle place et toi tu me
donnes quel poste vous me disiez non
mais c'était la question que vous me
posiez tout à l'heure je vous réponds
moi je suis maire de Rouen j'ai un
engagement et je tiens pardonner c'est
peut-être vieux jeu je tiens à l'honorer
voilà je tiens à ne pas cumuler à
honorer mon engagement politique et
moral et ensuite on regarde qui est
proche qui est proche Raphaël Glucksman
est très proche de nous il porte des
combats notamment sur les libertés
fondamentales les Ouigours sur l'Ukraine
les proches ça aurait du sens qu'on soit
ensemble en tout cas ça me semble
évident les écologistes sur le fond je
sais bien peuvent avoir des
considérations stratégiques différentes
on connaît leur histoire par rapport aux
européennes mais sur le fond honnêtement
on est proche de qui clairement nous
portons la sociale écologie il porte
l'écologie européenne il me semble que
l'on est très proche ils sont peut-être
un peu plus fédéraliste que certains
socialistes peut-être sont certainement
plus fédéralistes que les communistes
mais on est beaucoup plus proche PS plus
vite ou est-ce qu'il faut une liste avec
les écologistes d'abord
affirmant notre position sur le fond
parce que sinon on va être réduit à
négocier des places bon ensuite
travaillons avec les uns et avec les
autres moi je me suis engagé en
politique pour fait d'études politiques
je me suis engagé dans tout ça pour les
convictions et les idées et je pense que
c'est de ça dont on a besoin en premier
Erasmus pour tous Voilà une proposition
la gratuité des transports voilà une
proposition sur l'immigration travail
d'abord sur le logement social avec les
associations avec les bailleurs voilà
une proposition voilà c'est là où on
attend la gauche est-ce que vous est-ce
que c'est tenable encore pour le Parti
socialiste est-ce que vous pouvez rester
on a compris votre souhait de rester au
PS et de peser de l'intérieur mais
est-ce que vous pouvez le faire en
contestant quasi systématiquement la
ligne de Livier fort qui vous le voulez
oignon l'a emporter c'est lui le premier
secrétaire mais tu ne le conteste pas du
tout puisque c'est le résultat du
Congrès le résultat du Congrès il n'a
pas reconnu le vote du 19 janvier mais
il y a eu un accord politique pour dire
il y a un premier secrétaire qui est
Olivier forêt et puis il y a deux
premiers secrétaires délégués qui sont
joints à Roland et moi nous avons donc
la même légitimité définie par le
Congrès et lui comme promis ce crétaire
c'est tout à fait légitime mais moi je
suis loyaliste il y a aucune difficulté
là-dessus mais ça ne doit pas empêcher
d'avoir un débat sur le fond et de notre
point de vue et vous avez constaté les
résultats nous ne sommes pas les seuls à
penser cela nous pensons que et bien
l'accord de 2022 est ce qu'il est il
faut qu'on puisse le dépasser mais je
suis pas le seul à dire ça regardez
Fabien Roussel regardez marine
tondeuillier pour les européennes et
c'est pas grave et franchement dans
l'histoire socialiste il y a eu d'autres
combats Rocard Mitterrand Fabul Jospin
Aubry royal et ça les a pas empêché de
gagner des élections il y a un vrai
débat sur la gauche ce qui est sûr
aujourd'hui c'est que la gauche elle
gagne pas elle est faible alors est-ce
qu'on peut se passer des uns et des
autres de Bernard Cazeneuve du PRG de
l'écologie mais même de LFI François
Ruffin en Clémentine Autain bon mais il
dialogue moi j'ai lu avec attention le
débat entre par exemple Clémentine
Autain et Bernard Cazeneuve je pense que
c'est ça ils sont évidemment pas
d'accord surtout c'est pas grave mais là
où on attend les socialistes c'est sur
leur production insoumise 10 il y a pas
d'accord aux européennes c'est la fin de
la nuit
si vous n'êtes pas le petit doigt sur la
couture alors vous n'êtes plus de gauche
on n'est plus avec vous on veut plus
vous parler c'est pas comme ça qu'on
travaille la fin de la nuque non moi je
pense que on a besoin d'un rassemblement
de la gauche mais il est dépassé depuis
longtemps l'anus c'est à l'Assemblée
c'est pas au Sénat est-ce qu'on vous
parle de faire la nups au Sénat il y a
des élections sénatoriales est-ce que
vous voyez là la nuque au Sénat tout le
monde vous dit la nuque au Sénat non pas
du tout bon les municipales on va voir
ce qu'on va voir mais j'attends de voir
si tout le monde va m'expliquer qu'il il
faut que tout le monde soit rassemblé
pour les municipales vraiment on va
aller dire ça dans tous les territoires
alors que vous savez bien que il y a des
rassemblements qui sont divers bon et
qu'il peut y avoir et c'est normal c'est
la compétition électorale des objectifs
différents par famille politique mais
c'est pas grave c'est la démocratie à
condition de se respecter tout ce que
j'ai ajouté c'est que pour être respecté
il faut savoir se faire respecter et en
politique pour savoir se faire respecter
mais il faut être clair sur ce que l'on
est sur les idées qu'on a à proposer
c'est pour ça que je dis à tous les
anciens socialistes à tous ceux qui ont
pu être déçus ou qui sont sympathisants
mais qui n'osent pas franchir le pas
mais venez ou revenez parce que c'est à
l'intérieur qu'on peut changer les
choses parce que si vous vous occupez
pas de politique si vous restez à
l'extérieur si vous occupez pas de
politique la politique elle s'occupe de
vous la dernière question si je vous dis
3940 oui qu'est-ce que vous me répondez
chenille bon ben voilà c'est le record
le
records
3940 c'est le record du monde de la plus
longue chenille humaine qui a été battue
hier à Rouen dans le cadre de dans
l'Armada c'est mon petit moment de
solitude je vais vous répondre comme
cela on peut travailler sérieusement
sans se prendre au sérieux et je trouve
que c'est important et puis bon on adore
les Bretons j'adore je salue Loïc
girards de la région Bretagne est un ami
aussi j'ai beaucoup d'amis en Bretagne
enfin quand les Normands en battent les
Bretons ça ne me fait pas forcément de
peine alors justement parce qu'on parle
de l'Armada c'est l'événement évidemment
dans votre ville de Rouen c'est jusqu'à
dimanche le premier bilan on est à la
moitié extraordinaire positif
extraordinaire l'Armada est sans
prétention c'est un des plus beaux
rassemblements au monde dévoilé parce
que vous avez les plus grands voiliers
au monde c'est une fête populaire
extraordinaire des millions et des
millions de personnes on accueille le
monde entier venez avant vous savez rond
et pas toujours bien connu c'est vrai on
se pose souvent des questions sur sa vie
c'est une ville je disposso parce que
j'en suis maire évidemment ça a un
patrimoine incroyable c'est l'occasion
de découvrir cette ville qui est en
plein renouveau qui a tant à offrir en
plus on est candidats pour être capital
européenne de la culture en 2028 on un
projet magnifique venez découvrir tout
ça parce que c'est à la fois la fête la
fierté et puis le tout simplement le
plaisir de se retrouver ensemble c'est
votre badge absolument donc on va
essayer de zoomer si Philippe le
réalisateur y arrive mais c'est pas
simple jusqu'à quel est l'intérêt quel
est l'enjeu d'un tel label pour Rouen
vous souvenez peut-être de Marseille en
2013 je moi je pense beaucoup à Lille en
2004 et encore aujourd'hui Lille a été
capitale européenne en 2004 et il y a un
avant et un après pour Lille et Martine
Aubry le dit très bien et Pierre Mauroy
avant il s'est passé quelque chose à
travers la culture c'est la culture
c'est ce qui nous rassemble c'est
absolument essentiel et puis c'est
évidemment aussi un projet de territoire
nous le cœur de notre candidature c'est
d'arriver à réconcilier et c'est l'enjeu
de ce siècle en réalité la nature
l'environnement l'industrie la science
le réchauffement climatique tout ça
c'est très anxiogène et l'humain et
l'humain au cœur de tout ça parce que
pour beaucoup de Français et de français
on se sent dépossédés c'est très dur
quand vous avez la pandémie le
réchauffement climatique des usines qui
ferment comment est-ce qu'on remet du Ré
lentement dans tout ça par la culture
alors c'est dur c'est aussi la
confrontation c'est ça le coeur de notre
problématique et c'est une problématique
tellement européenne et même mondiale un
dernier mot parce que vous avez reçu
Édouard Philippe pierre oui dans votre
ville en tant que mer du Havre bien sûr
on imagine
très bien ensemble
non non pas du tout mais vous savez en
travaillant ensemble enfin franchement
Le Havre et Rouen c'est le même destin
parce que c'est le même bassin de vie
c'est la vallée de scène d'ailleurs il
soutient aussi notre candidature comme
Anne Hidalgo d'ailleurs ce qui prouve
que dans l'intérêt du pays parce que
l'enjeu de la vallée de scène c'est un
enjeu national parce que c'est le
corridor d'accès de la capitale à la mer
et toutes les grandes capitales du monde
ont un accès à la mer quand il y a un
enjeu qui nous dépasse il faut savoir se
rassembler et ça je pense que c'est une
leçon pour tous les élus merci merci
Nicolas meilleur Rossignol merci d'avoir
été notre invité la Une de Ouest-France
Stéphane c'est l'Ukraine
Ukraine l'offensive de Kev sur le front
sud merci Stéphane à la semaine
prochaine merci on passe au club des
territoires